matvey as Prime Minister crystianna's  karinch will present his views on the  future of Europe  members vote on fitting all new vehicles  with compulsory life-saving features  such as intelligent speed assistance and  emergency stop signals from 2020 to four  new models and from 2024 for existing  ones measures to strengthen EU borders  with a 10,000 strong border and Coast  Guard core will be put to a vote the aim  is to better respond to the migration  and security needs of Member States  members vote on EU wide rules to protect  those who disclose information on  illegal or harmful work-related  activities measures include safeguards  against retaliation and legal aid  Parliament wants online terrorist  content to be removed from platforms  within one hour of receiving an order to  do so but companies will not have to  filter all content there should be  penalties for breaches but also  safeguards to protect freedom of speech